AvAvec nous ce soir, pour notre
papanel, Stéphanie Grammond
AlAlec Castonguay et Hélène
BuBuzzetti. Bonsoir à vous troi.
- - (tous): Bonsoir.
- - Commençons par les
ininfirmières. J'ai entendu vote
enentrevue avec sur les ondes de
lala radio de Canada avec la mêe
ididée que j'avais précédemment.
LeLe discours n'a pas vraiment
chchangé. On comprend qu'il y a
unune espèce de cristallisation,
c'c'est-à-dire que les infirmiès
titiennent vraiment, et délégué
sysyndical vraiment à ce que
cecelles qui sont libérées une
fofois par semaine et accès aux
fafameuses primes pour attirer
cecelles qui ont quitté le serve
pupublic à revenir. Et on comprd
ququ'il y a vraiment un enjeu ac
l'l'ancienneté parce qu'on se dt
: : si on remet des conditions
inintéressantes pour celles qui
onont quitté, nécessairement
cecelles qui sont restées qui vt
enen payer le prix. Est-ce que
vovous voyez une résolution, une
fafaçon d'arriver à une entente
enentre le gouvernement et les
sysyndicats?
- - Je pense q que la question s
prprimes pour les délégués
sysyndicaux, c'est un peu facilà
rérégler. C'est peut-être l'objt
brbrillant qui détourne
l'l'attention. Ça fait de la boe
clclips en conférence de presset
jeje pense que c'est assez facie
àà régler. Ce qui est plus
cocompliqué, c'est le volet et
JuJulie vous avait accroché sura
mmême partie que moi lors de
vovotre entrevue, la question de
l'l'ancienneté. Et ça, il n'y a
papas véritablement de bonnes ou
dede mauvaises positions. C'est-
didire que les deux côtés ont ds
bobons arguments. Quelques
inindividus : si je tente de
coconvaincre les infirmières à a
reretraite qui sont dans le
sesecteur privé de revenir au
pupublic, je ne peux pas les
enenvoyer en bas de la liste de
rarappel et qu'elle choisisse en
dedernier pour les vacances et
ququ'elle n'a jamais de congés.
ElElles vont parvenir et je ne
seserai pas capable d'en
coconvaincre. Les syndicats dist
: : si vous faites cela vous alz
rérétrograder dans la liste ceux
etet celles qui ont fait l'effot
dede rester dans le public et qi
onont fait des heures
susupplémentaires obligatoires,
ququi ont tenu le réseau à boute
brbras dans les dernières année.
EtEt donc d'aller faire de la
plplace à ceux qui se sont sauvs
etet vous avez besoin de les
raramener. C'est un excellent
arargument aussi du côté des
sysyndicats de ne pas laisser ca
sese produire. Alors ce sera
cocompliqué. Il faut s'assoit et
êêtre capable de trouver un
teterrain d'entente que ça ne se
fefera pas conférence de presse
ininterposée ni dans les médias,
mamais c'est clair que c'est un
popoint d'achoppement très
imimportant dans la stratégie de
rerecrutement de gouvernement
acactuellement.
- - Stéphanie, comment vous
exexpliquez cette sortie du
miministre hier parce que c'est
trtrès frontal. On ne se fait ps
d'd'amis avec ce genre de sorti.
- - Je pense que cela a été un u
brbrutal et dans le fond, un tao
sese danse à deux. Alors je ne
crcrois pas que c'est en faisant
dedes sorties médiatiques comme
cecela que le ministre va arrivr
àà ses fins. C'est sûr que c'est
pepeut-être un peu un calcul
fafacile que de dire : les
rereprésentants syndicaux de toe
fafaçon ne sont pas nécessairemt
leles gens les plus populaires
dadans l'opinion publique. Alors
sisi on peut casser un peu de
susucre sur leur dos, ça va peu-
êêtre nous faire marquer des
popoints. Mais ce n'est pas come
cecela qu'on va arriver à une
enentente avec les infirmières t
ilil faut négocier, il faut
s's'assoit. Donc je pense que ça
nene se fait pas de en conférene
dede presse, devant les caméras.
EtEt le ministre Dubé n'a pas le
chchoix, il a besoin de ces
ininfirmières pour faire
fofonctionner le réseau. Il a ft
dedes premières il y a plusieurs
momois de rattraper des opératis
ququi sont en retard, ce n'est s
cocomme ça qu'il est en voie
d'd'arriver à ses fins.
- - Hélène, vous voyez ça comme?
- - Vous l'avez dit tout à l'hee
enentrevu qu'il y a quand même e
jojoute de relations publiques
dadans toute cette affaire est
clclairement quand même, le
miministre Dubé se cherche un bc
émémissaire pour expliquer le ft
quque son opération ne fonctione
papas. On l'a déjà vu avec les
mémédecins, on a frappé fort sur
leles médecins qui ne prennent s
susuffisamment de patients. Là,n
papasse aux infirmières et comme
lele disait Stéphanie, les
dédélégués syndicaux ne sont pas
nénécessairement ceux qui
rérécoltent le plus de popularié
dadans la population. Alors c'et
fafacile de marquer des points
popolitiques comme cela.
OnOn comprend un peu la
frfrustration du gouvernement qi
esest probablement légitime et
ququi, dans une situation
exexceptionnelle, cherche à
trtrouver des mécanismes
exexceptionnels, des solutions
exexceptionnelles qui dérogent
pepeut-être des cadres rigides
hahabituels. Et bon, frustration
dudu fait que ça ne débouche pa.
MaMais je constate quand même ue
cecertaine rigidité de part et
d'd'autre. On parle de
l'l'ancienneté, je pense que Alc
l'l'a très bien expliqué. Il y a
auaussi une rigidité peut-être u
ccôté du gouvernement sur cette
ququestion des congés de maladi,
sisi on s'absente pour une joure
dede congé, on perd la prime.
- - Ça semble tellement restricf
etet quand on se met à l'du
sysyndicat, on se dit que pour n
cocongé de maladie, suivi de
grgrossesse ou en congé de décè,
c'c'est impensable de penser qun
vava perdre la prime.
- - Et on comprend aussi la
poposition sur les délégués
sysyndicaux. Si on n'est pas
cacapable d'accorder une prime à
ququelqu'un qui s'attendrait por
dedeux ou trois suivis de
grgrossesse image de quelqu'un i
s's'attendrait une fois par
sesemaine pour son syndicat.
- - On va passer un autre dossir
mamais on reste dans cette
ququestion de ton encore parce e
cece n'est pas avec les que le n
paparfois et cinglant. Aujourd'i
unun député libéral, Marc Tangu,
sese fait traiter de complotistà
l'l'assemblée nationale par le
miministre Simon Jolin-Barrette.
SISIMON JOLIN-BARRETTE,
leleader parlementaire de la CAQ
- - Est-ce que le député
dede Lafontaine nie la pandémie,
MoMonsieur le Président?
EsEst-ce que le député
dede Lafontaine, depuis mars 20,
esest conscient qu'il y a
unune pandémie mondiale?
EsEst-ce que le député de
LaLafontaine nie cette réalité-?
EsEst-ce qu'il croit que c'est n
cocomplot? Est-il un complotist,
MoMonsieur le Président,
MoMonsieur le Président?
FRFRANÇOIS PARADIS, président,
AsAssemblée nationale du Québec
- - S'il vous plaît, s'il vous
plplaît, je vais vous demander
enencore une fois de faire...
JeJe viens de dire d'être prudet
dadans les termes.
J Je crois que mon intervention
ététait on ne peut plus claire.
CeCe que je vais dire maintenan,
c'c'est que je ne veux plus
réréentendre ce terme à l'égard
dede quiconque parmi les député.
- - C'était peut-être la dernièe
fofois que vous allez entendre e
momot complotiste lancé comme ue
ininsulte à l'armée nationale il
rereste qu'il y a quand même
ququelque chose de questionnable
llà-dedans, c'est-à-dire en
imimpression que le gouvernement
LeLegault maintenant, autrement
ququ'il y a une critique de la
papart de l'opposition, il se ft
raramasser et repérer cocomme ds
crcrêpes. En l'occurrence, cette
fofois-ci c'était sur
l'l'utilisation de l'état
d'd'urgence sanitaire pour
pepermettre de gouverner par
dédécrets. Évidemment, les parts
d'd'opposition en ont assez. De
sosoulever la question, c'est
ququand même légitime, Stéphani?
- - C'est absolument légitime et
jeje pense que le comportement u
miministre Simon Jolin-Barrette,
hohonnêtement à l'Assemblée
nanationale, l'après-midi, avait
plplus l'd'une cour de récréatin
quque d'un endroit où on est
susupposé débattre de questions
imimportantes. Et oui, c'en est
unune question importante. L'étt
d'd'urgence, c'est quand même,
dadans une société démocratique,
c'c'est quand même quelque chose
ququi devrait être remis en
ququestion. On sait que depuis n
momois ou deux, il y a des
alallégements, les gens
rereprennent, retourne travaill,
reretourne à l'école, les choses
rerentrent dans l'ordre. Donc
ulultimement il va falloir enler
cecette disposition et faire
prpreuve de transparence. Donc
c'c'est tout à fait légitime dea
papart de l'opposition de posera
ququestion et ce n'est pas norml
ququ'on se fasse répondre sur ce
toton.
- - Un petit mot là-dessus, Ale?
- - On a la peau très sensible
nonotamment depuis le retour en
chchambre cet automne, peu impoe
lele sujet, que ce soit la sant,
leles syndicats, avec les partis
d'd'opposition. On ne un peu des
dédéshabitués à avoir des
crcritiques dans les derniers ms
dede la pandémie. Le ministre
SiSimon Jolin-Barrette s'est
exexcusé ensuite sur Twitter, et
ilil a réagi fortement parce que
pependant la première année et
dedemie de la pandémie, c'était
totout à fait justifié avoir
l'l'état d'urgence jusqu'à
prprobablement septembre de cete
anannée il y avait de bonnes
raraisons d'avoir des contrats
sasans appel d'offres, de pouvor
sususpendre les conventions
cocollectives en santé, de
ororganiser le réseau à l'abri s
coconventions collectives. Depus
seseptembre, c'est de moins en
momoins justifiable et les parts
opoppositions augmente la pressn
etet c'est cela qui agace le
gogouvernement. La semaine
prprochaine va pouvoir danser et
chchanter dans des karaokés. Çae
fafait pas très état d'urgence,
didisons-le comme ça. On peut
cecertainement être capable de
momoduler certaines des
didispositions pour être capable
dede se priver de cet état
d'd'urgence sans que tous les
fofondre. Le gouvernement dit :
ququand les cinq à 11 ans seront
vavaccinés on va lever l'état
d'd'urgence. Ça devrait être en
jajanvier mais c'est clair que
cecela agace le gouvernement que
leles parties oppositions remete
enen question pour
- - Pour la vaccination des
jejeunes, il reste encore beaucp
d'd'étapes dont l'acceptation ds
paparents de faire vacciner leus
enenfants. Il y a beaucoup de
crcritiques envers le gouvernemt
dede la CAQ c'est ainsi qu'il se
fafait accuser d'être trop
auautoritaire. Ça revient souve.
OnOn rentre en année électorale.
EsEst-ce que la CAQ devrait avor
plplus de prudence dans son tems
etet sa manière avec les parties
opoppositions?
- - La CAQ est tellement populae
quque je ne la vois pas très
memenacée en ce moment mais ence
quque l'élection est dans un an.
DeDe manière générale, ce qui et
agagaçant, et j'élargirai le
cocommentaire pas seulement à la
CACAQ mais cette espèce
d'd'unanimisme qui est exigé das
lele contexte sanitaire, c'est
cocomme s'il n'était plus possie
d'd'avoir un discours alternati,
lélégèrement différent. Il parat
mmême le lien avec la question e
lala vaccination obligatoire, et
onon n'en parlera peut-être un u
plplus tard tout à l'heure, à
OtOttawa ou c'est vraiment
d'd'actualité. Il est comme plus
popossible dans le contexte
d'd'apporter de quelconque nuan,
totout doit être ou bien droit u
bibien blanc mais surtout blanct
sisinon vous êtes dans le même
papanier que les complotiste.
C'C'est un peu agaçant et ça nos
fafait perdre quand même une
nunuance importante dans le débt
pupublic et ça va nous faire
papasser à côté peut-être de
cecertains enjeux qui sont
pepertinents sur la question dea
vavaccination obligatoire
nonotamment en milieu de travai.
CÇa soulève deses questions très
imimportantes et c'est comme sin
avavait plus le droit d'en parlr
paparce que tout de suite on est
ététiqueté comme étant un fou
fufurieux essentiellement.
- - Donc on a perdu de vue
l'l'nuance finalement. On va
paparler de la scène fédérale
paparce que là aussi il se passe
dedes choses. Tous les partis ot
tetenté de se préparer pour la
rerentrée parlementaire officiee
2222 novembre. Parlons des
coconservateurs. On essaie de se
réréorganiser. Ils ont dévoilé
cecette semaine leur cabinet
fafantôme. Et vous allez lancere
babas là-dessus Hélène parce que
lala critique revient ou en fait
l'l'observation qui revient c'et
quque dans le cabinet fantôme, e
sosont des critiques des
didifférents ministères mais ily
a a plus de critiques de minist.
QuQuel est le but? Faire plaisià
totout le monde?
- - Un peu de ça, beaucoup de
crcritiques et aussi des critiqs
adadjoint. Il y a une liste
prpresque aussi longue. Ça fait
bebeaucoup de monde, c'est une
fafaçon de mettre en vedette, en
évévidence nos députés,
d'd'améliorer leur profil
nonotamment. Il y a une nominatn
quque je trouve assez
inintéressante, celle de Michele
ReRempel aux ressources
nanaturelles. C'est un choix
paparticulier parce que cette de
esest très affirmatif sur les
ququestions du pétrole, de
prprotéger sa province, Alberta.
ElElle avait été cicatrice de
cecette Buffalo declaration,.
CeCette déclaration du bison sur
pepeut traduire. Et c'est
ququelqu'un de très affirmative.
CÇa risque de camper encore une
fofois le Parti conservateur coe
lele protecteur de l'Alberta et
çaça, lorsqu'on cherche à faire
dedes gains en Ontario et au
QuQuébec, ce n'est pas
nénécessairement ce qui est le
plplus gagnant.
- - On note aussi le retour de
AlAlain Rayes comme une politiqe
àà la place de Richard Martel
ququi, rappelons-nous était celi
ququi avait appuyé la course à a
chchefferie deux Erin O'Toole. n
coconsidère finalement, on n'a s
eueu les résultats escomptés
mamanifestement Québec alors ona
mimis aussi la photo de Gérard
DeDeltell. Lui aussi reste comme
leleader parlementaire. Que
pepensez-vous de ces choix et
ququ'est-ce que ça indique?
- - Je pense que c'est un
exexcellent choix Erin O'Toole.
MoMonsieur Martel, on l'avait ms
dadans cette position parce qu'l
avavait été l'un des premiers
apappuis d'Erin O'Toole mais ça
n'n'en fait pas nécessairement n
bobon lieutenant ou un bon
ororganisateur. Alain Rayes au
contraire avait réussi lors de
l'l'élection précédente mais qui
s's'était soldée par le même
rérésultltat tu Andrew Scheer qe
sosourient nos tôles, il avait e
brbrochette de candidats de très
grgrande qualité malgré qu'il
avavait ramené d'autres courant.
C'C'est un vrai rassembleur, ila
totout d'un bon lieutenant, Alan
RaRayes alors cette espèce de li
reretirer cela mais on comprenat
lala joute interne qui avait poé
dadans la balance. De le ramener
cocomme cela, je pense qu'il y a
unune humidité chez Erin O'Tool,
ilil a prie la bonne décision et
popour les conservateur du Québc
sesera plus efficace d'avoir Aln
RaRayes et Monsieur Martel
rereconnaisse en disant : peut-
êêtre que ce n'est pas là que je
pepeux être le plus efficace en
popolitique.
- - Il a pas été oublié dans le
cacabinet fantôme. Au critique
fifinance ramène Pierre Poilièv.
Il a tout un style, on ne peut
papas le manquer quand il parlen
chchambre.
- - Oui, et même moi je me
bobornerai à dire sur le cabinet
fafantôme de M. O'Toole grandemt
auautant de personnes, c'est pe-
êêtre la preuve que justement il
y y a de la difficulté à faire s
chchoix, il a de la difficulté à
sese commettre et il veut faire
plplaisir à tout le monde. Et
cocomme son parti est extrêmemet
didivisé, ça nous amène tout le
tetemps dans une situation où on
nene sait pas à quelle adresse l
esest. Et un bonjour il va fallr
ququ'il présente une vision clae
etet unique parce qu'autrement,e
ciciment ne m'a jamais collé.
- - Mais il a quand même présené
unun peu plus de clarté en
écécartant de son cabinet fantôe
lala députée Marilyn Gladu. Cete
MmMme Blais du haver dit des
chchoses sur la pandémie qui avt
scscandalisé bien des gens en
didisant que ce n'était pas plus
grgrave que d'autres maladies,
etetc. Elle s'est excusée par la
susuite et elle est dit que
c'c'était important de faire la
prpromotion de l'accès mais elle
titient un autre discours. Cela
didit il y a quand même une sore
dede punition par son expulsione
cece cabinet mais ça envoie un
memessage, non? C'est une sortee
mimise en garde pour tous les
auautres.
- - On peut le voir comme cela
ququoi que je dois dire que c'et
ququand même un peu dommage pare
quque Mme Gladu, elle a eu ce
cocommentaire malheureux qu'elle
ararrête rapidement et je crois
ququ'elle a voulu faire une
cocomparaison historique assez
boboiteuse. Mais Marilyn Gladu
n'n'est pas un élément extrémise
dudu caucus conservateur, c'est
ququelqu'un d'assez posé que
ququelqu'un de très agréable, ue
bobonne tête sur les épaules. On
avavait même songé à se porter
cacandidate à la succession
d'd'Andrew Scheer.
CeCe fameux caucus qu'elle veut
crcréer, certaines présentent
cocomme peut-être caucus des ani
vavaccinations et peut-être quea
dedeviendra effectivement le
rerepère des députés non vaccins
ouou des députés qui ne croient
papas à la vaccination.
MaMais le but avoué et on verrai
c'c'est cela qui arrive, mais le
bubut avoué pour revenir sur ce
quque je disais tout à l'heure,
c'c'est de faire un peu une
rerecherche sur les conséquences
dede la vaccination obligatoire
dadans le milieu de travail sur
leles citoyens et ce n'est quand
mmême pas inintéressant. On peut
sese poser la question si le
mamatin, tous les employeurs du
CaCanada exigent la vaccination,
esest-ce que ça voudrait donc de
ququ'il n'existe plus de libre
chchoix et que les gens qui ont
dedes réticences, même si on les
cocondamne, envers la vaccinati,
ququi n'ont plus le droit de
trtravailler? C'est quand même e
ququestion qui mérite d'être
ététudiée et si le comité qu'ele
enentend créer, Madame Marilyn
GlGladu, se limite à cela, ça pt
avavoir une vertu mais
popolitiquement, c'est clair que
cecela nuit au conservateur pare
quque cela permet aux adversairs
dede les étiqueter comme étant s
huhurluberlus qui ne croient paà
la s science.
- - Pas une rentrée légèrement
fafacile pour M. O'Toole. Un
dedernier mot maintenant sur le
BlBloc québécois. Il y avait un
popoint de presse aujourd'hui de
momonsieur Blanchet qui a préseé
seses priorités. S'il y a eu des
coconversations entre le NPD, le
PaParti libéral pour essayer dee
mamaintenir et ne pas basculer n
élélection trouvée. Le bloc n'a
papas eu droit à ce genre de
coconversation de monsieur
BlBlanchet dit : on sera un
inincontournable. Est-ce qu'il
sesera vraiment quel est le fond
dede l'histoire?
- - C'est-à-dire qu'ils sont
imimportants mais ils ne sont ps
inincontournables dans la mesure
ouoù cette pour faire des
alalliances ponctuelles avec le
NPNPD, donc contourner le Bloc
ququébécois et même parfois avec
lele Parti conservateur même si
c'c'est un peu contre nature et
paparfois avec le Bloc québécoi.
JeJe ne crois pas trop trop de
paparler d'alliance formelle ene
lele NPD et le Parti libéral.
PrProbablement que l'on se parle
popour connaître les priorités e
chchacun pour le discours du Tre
etet être capable d'avoir un pln
dede masse qui se tient. On n'a
papas besoin chez les libéraux e
fafaire des concessions, on a le
grgros bout du bâton, personne e
veveut retourner en élection das
la situation actuelle. Je pense
quque le bloc est un jour
imimportant, il est
inincontournable, c'est le
didiscours de faux-semblants
jajamais en réalité ils vont ête
imimportants sur certains enjeux
etet sur d'autres libéraux vont
s's'appuyer ailleurs. Je pense
ququ'il va y avoir beaucoup de
didifférence dans la dynamique r
rarapport à auparavant ce n'est
quque personne ne veut retourner
enen élection.
- - Au moins on s'entend là-dess
popour maintenant. On ne peut
jajamais pour l'avenir. Merc